thank you pft pm posse with some
questions posed so uh we can continue to
talk about football while we it's hard
to do a draft with one person this would
be the time in the show where we would
do our match-up draft
for week 15. draft isn't as fun when
it's just one person it's like one
person playing checkers it really isn't
fun for anyone including the person
playing checkers how about this question
from coach clough
for the next 10 years if you had to bet
on super bowl outcomes would you take
mahomes and the chiefs winning
five out of ten or would you pick the
field
i did have a dream last night that the
chiefs
won this year not that that's any type
of a stretch
but we were covering it even though
we're not going to be there and
travis kelsey i think has a really big
game and andy reid talking about
hamburgers again
i don't know i think this is just when
your life starts to infiltrate your
dreams but the idea of the chiefs
winning isn't nearly as crazy as pretty
much any other team in the league
the chiefs the favorite now the betting
favorite to win the super bowl and
even though i'm not a big fan of taking
one team when i can take the field when
the field has 31 of them
at this point in the season i wouldn't
have done it before week one
at this point in the season i'll take
the chiefs for this year five out of the
next 10 though
there's just too many things that can
happen
over the course of 10 years injuries
other teams catching up maybe there's
another patrick mahomes out there that's
going to
show up and level the playing field
maybe that patrick mahomes is going to
land in the afc west
and the chiefs are going to face a
tougher fight every year to try to get
the best possible playoff positioning
five out of the next 10
i'm taking the field versus the chiefs
uh i
i just we can't expect that to happen
the patriots never
got five out of ten i have to go back
and do my math they had clusters of
three
out of four twice but they were spread
apart
by ten years so even the patriots with
tom brady and bill belichick never won
five in in 10 years
at joe paul 722 if the nfl expands to 17
games will players make more money or
will they play for the same amount per
existing contract part of the
negotiation
back in march addressed that i believe
there was so much going on in march with
the pandemic and everything but
i think it's just as simple as taking
their current contract and adding a week
at their current rate i believe that's
what happens
and the other side of it too more money
becomes more salary cap
room more salary cap space more spending
that can be done
by the individual team so the players
currently not under contract
or the players whose contracts will
expire in the future will have more
money that they can try to get in their
individual negotiations
and also if there's more cap space that
guy who's got the five or six million
dollar
non-guaranteed contract who may have to
worry about being cut
he doesn't have to worry about being cut
or at least not as much
if there's more cap space because then
there's less of an urgency
to get that guy's cap number in line
with what the cap is so it's a win for
the players
yes there are plenty of them that don't
want to play a 17th game there are real
health and safety questions about
whether or not it makes sense to expose
players
to that extra game but there will be
without question more money in the
system to pay existing players
to pay rookies to keep guys on the
roster who otherwise would be potential
cap casualties
another one from joe paul 72 who gets
the number two seed in the afc the bills
or the steelers right now the bills are
ten and three the steelers eleven and
two the bills hold the head-to-head
tiebreaker
and the steelers don't have the colts
and the browns one of the
disappointments from monday night even
though i picked the ravens to win and i
love being right
the reality is that with the browns
losing this late season possibility of
the browns catching the steelers
has gone out the window unless the
steelers would lose to the bengals
on monday night the browns don't have a
chance to win the division
the question is do the bills have a
chance to catch the steelers i have a
feeling based on how the steelers have
been playing lately
they're going to lose one of these next
two games now that doesn't mean the
bills are going to run the table
but right now i think the bills are
going to end up with the number two seed
and you know that may not be a good
thing because the ravens if they get the
number seven seed i don't know that i
want to mess with the ravens
in the wild card round i'd love to see a
steelers ravens rematch i'd love to see
a browns ravens rematch in the
postseason the ravens
as we've said yesterday they may be able
to get past
this question of whether or not they're
going to fall flat on their faces in the
playoffs
by treating the final five games of the
regular season like playoff games
they're going to be in playoff mode
they're not at home like they were in
2018 against the chargers
they're not at home like they were in
2019 after a week off against
the titans and remember they shut it
down for a lot of the key starters week
17 so it's three weeks between games for
lamar jackson
and some of the other key players this
year there's the urgency
there's the panic the desperation that
contributes quite possibly
to the ravens being impervious to this
question of whether or not they're going
to fail in the post season
they've already been winning playoff
games they've won five
what's one more or two more or three
mowers so they can be very dangerous
i don't whatever the seating is round
one
wild card i don't want the ravens
to be my draw if they get in
another question from not your butler
who is the 49ers quarterback in the
future
good question good question and you know
i learned
several years ago that anyone who says
good question means i don't know
so i'm going to buy some time and think
about it while i say that's a good
question so can i say to you not your
butler that was a
very good question nobody knows who
their quarterback is going to be
it shouldn't be jimmy garoppolo for one
very specific reason i know there's a
lot of people out there why do you hate
jimmy garoppolo look i i don't like
i don't hate jimmy garoppolo i i like
quarterbacks who are able to play
and you can't be a franchise quarterback
if he can't play now there's always a
chance of a catastrophic injury that's
going to knock you out like tom brady
when he
took a low hit week one of the 2008
season and wasn't able to play because
he had a torn acl
but this constant injury injury injury
and
so many games missed by jimmy garoppolo
and i understand that there's an
explanation for every one of them
although for his acl the explanation is
he was trying to be tough guy along the
sideline dropping his shoulder and
delivering a hit when he didn't need to
and he tore his acl when he dropped his
shoulder to deliver the hit to a kansas
city chief's defensive back
just get out of bounds just suppress the
ego
and the machismo and the urgency to
prove to people that you're tough enough
you have to be able to play and for
garoppolo we haven't seen enough
of him and i think for that reason they
need to be looking at all options and
you know as chris said the other day you
can't slam the door on garoppolo unless
you know who your plan
b is but at the same time
i don't know at a certain point you just
say
we'll take our chances with plan b plan
b is now plan a
because plan a hasn't worked we've tried
it
and it just hasn't been successful for
us
matt mcsee will the steelers rest
everyone for the final two weeks of the
season after they clinch the division
against cincinnati i don't know
but but why would you rest your your
starters for the last two games you've
got the colts you've got the browns
you i understand that the one seed make
well i don't know the one seed still
potentially in play
i'm not a big fan of resting starters i
understand you're exposing your guys to
risk
i i just don't like it because you you
you potentially jeopardize your
readiness for the playoffs and if you're
going to play in the wild card round
anyway
there is some value maybe in considering
shutting guys down for week 17
but i want to know exactly what the
stakes are if you truly have nothing to
play for
maybe you consider resting guys week 17.
i'm just not a big fan of that
i i say keep it going keep it rolling
but for the steelers they've had such a
weird year maybe they would benefit
from a true bye week they never had a
bye week this year their bye week ended
up being a week where they got ready to
play the bills
or was it the titans it was when they
got ready to play the titans for crying
out loud not the bills they just played
the bills this week
their bye week was the week they spent
getting ready to play the titans and
then they didn't play the titans and
they played the titans three weeks after
that
so they haven't had a true bye week
there may be value to it i just
i just generally say be very careful
about consciously pulling the plug
on your team because sometimes it may be
difficult to put the plug back in the
socket when you need to
another question rodri jones 32 will an
offensive lineman ever win an ap award
jason kelsey deserved
offensive rookie of the year in his
first season i thought i think shireen
williams has said
that she voted for quentin nelson of the
colts the year that
he was a rookie for uh the indianapolis
colts
um i just don't think it ever happens
because look
this is the dynamic of football when the
offensive line is playing great what
does
that do it allows the quarterback
the running backs the receivers the
tight end to have better seasons
so statistically those players become
the stars
while the offensive linemen are grinding
it out in relative anonymity
you typically only know about offensive
linemen when they're not playing well
and guys are running past them and you
say who the hell is that guy
that is letting the defensive end
continue to run past him and get to the
quarterback if they're playing well
unless it's spectacular and i remember
when
the term pancake block entered the
lexicon back in the 70s or the 80s and i
remember when bill
fralek remember that name was it pit
many of you don't
the the concept that he was just putting
guys on their butts all the time i mean
if you're doing something spectacular
where you just steamroll a guy into the
front row of the stadium
that's when you get noticed that's when
people pay attention to you as an
offensive lineman that just doesn't
happen very often
it's more about in today's game pass
blocking
how many offensive linemen are throwing
guys onto their butts when they're past
blocking it's more of a defensive
posture
where you're fending off the attacker
and trying to steer him away from your
quarterback so
it's just very difficult for an
offensive lineman because when an
offensive lineman is playing well
his teammates are playing well and those
are the people
who will be getting the major awards
kevin
kelly what is the percentage chance bill
belichick tanks week 17 versus the jets
to screw them out
of the first overall pick you know
people have been
throwing around that possibility and
the patriots in a position that really
they haven't been in in a long time
matthew slater special teams captain had
to talk about
where he finds his motivation this is
the first season of his career when he's
playing out the string
you know if if you truly don't want to
spend the next 10 or 15 years dealing
with trevor lawrence and if you intend
to continue to be the coach of the
patriots for the next 10 or 15 years
yeah there's there's merit in laying
down
the jets i i'd be stunned if it happens
and i can't help but wonder even if it's
the patriots
b team or c team would they still lose
to the jets could the jets beat the back
end of the patriots roster because
that's how tanking really happens
nobody's not
dead he's really trying the players
aren't trying to lose the team puts
lesser players on the field and hope
nature will take take its course
like the buccaneers did in the final
week of the
2014 season when at halftime they were
leading the saints by double digits they
pulled all their good players they put
their bad players in the saints came
back and won
and the buccaneers got jameis winston
even though jameis winston ultimately
didn't work out
that's what they wanted to do that's
what they did that's how it would work
i don't know that bill belichick would
do that but he's so strategic about
everything
if he doesn't want the jets to get
trevor lawrence and if it comes down to
losing to the jets week 17
to keep the jets from getting trevor
lawrence and if the game has
no impact whatsoever on the patriots
in any way shape or form then yeah why
not do it and i've been saying for years
now
once you know you're not gonna get to
the playoffs who cares if you're seven
and nine or six and ten or five and
eleven who cares it's not like bill
belichick has to worry about his job
you get a higher draft pick and maybe
you keep the jets from getting trevor
lawrence
so uh whether he will or not
it's hard to make the argument that he
shouldn't especially if you're a
patriots fan that doesn't want to deal
with trevor lawrence if he ends up being
a great nfl quarterback gordo cleveland
is kevin stefanski the greatest coach
ever or the most handsome coach ever
i'll hang up and listen
uh well um gordo i don't i don't know
that we can really resolve either one of
those yet
he's got a lot of competition on the
latter category on the former category
he's got a long way to go but what he's
done so far this year
as we've established and now he's as
we've discussed he should be
the favorite we had the betting odds
yesterday if we have the graphic
available we can throw it up that would
be great mike tomlin was the favorite
i believe when we talked about it
yesterday to be coach of the year kevin
stefanski was like
plus 900 if i recall correctly and
there's a good chance i don't
i like the bet of kevin stefanski i like
the chances of kevin stefanski i would
vote
for kevin szyfanski as coach of the year
nine and
four right now having the browns on the
brink of the playoffs for the first time
since 2002 and even though there was
talent there
they didn't get it done last year and he
undid some damage
brought in some new systems without the
benefit of an offseason program
he's turned that team around i'm very
impressed with what the browns have done
and there it is mike tomlin plus 175 and
i was right
plus 900 for a change is kevin stefanski
a lot of great
candidates though for coach of the year
this is one that's going to be
determined based on what happens the
last three weeks and even then
even then we're not going to know and
and i've been advocating this for years
associated press if you're listening and
there's a good chance you aren't
why do we do this one person one vote
for these awards
first place second place third place
weight the votes that way and then what
it allows is
a broader swath you get more people who
get recognition so when the final
numbers are tabulated
you get more people who who deserve
recognition for a great season getting
votes
and this year the vote could be all over
the place
for coach of the year we'll see how that
plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports